Breaking news The federal
election interference
case against Donald Trump is now
postponed indefinitely.
The trial was scheduled
to start March 4th,
but the ongoing appeals about Tr
claims of presidential immunity
are making that start date impos
And Ryan Goodman is OUTFRONT.
So, Ryan,
here we are
that this has been postponed
indefinitely.
And I guess,
you know,
they're are waiting an immunity
But what does that mean?
I mean, I understand it's
we knew it was going to be postp
Right.
I mean, that was understandable
at this point
because we haven't gotten the ru
But nonetheless, indefinitely
does sort of have a heavy weight
It most certainly does,
because the judge, Judge
Turton, could have put down anot
somewhat provisional date
for start of trial,
but she didn't,
which gives us a sense of
just how suspended
the action currently is as we aw
the D.C.
Circuit and as she even suggeste
and when she gets the mandate
from the D.C. Circuit.
So it could be
that by the time they issue a ma
her calendar is already full.
So it really is just going to be
to see when that trial could sta
and if it could even start in th
or the summer at all,
which, I mean, it's incredible
that we've reached this moment.
I mean, advisers to the former
president are telling CNN,
you know, given
what you're saying,
that they think this is a win
for Trump in the campaign.
Is it that clear cut?
I'm not sure
it's that clear cut,
but it's certainly a good day fo
This is good news for him.
The reason that it might not be
that clear cut
is that in a certain sense,
the district court is sending a
to the D.C. Circuit.
She's basically
saying in a certain sense,
this is be
this is very disruptive to the t
Now, I've had to suspend everyth
So that puts a little bit
extra pressure on the D.C.
Circuit to rule.
And so we might still see
a ruling from the D.C. Circuit.
Then the Supreme Court decides
whether or not it wants to act.
And then everything could be put
could be put back on track.
So definitely a good day
for President Trump,
but not necessarily out of the w
So in the context of what this m
for the other trials
against Trump, obviously,
you know,
you've got the question marks in
that are out there right now
that that could mean
Alvin Bragg's Hush Money case,
which is the one that had been s
as the most politicized.
But it is a criminal case
that could be the one that goes
first after all of this. Right.
When he had
sort of acquiesced and moved it
so that that wouldn't be the cas
But it looks like it's conceivab
that it is first. Now.
I would
bet my money on the idea
that that's going to be the firs
And it might be the only case.
It might be the only criminal ca
that's actually brought to trial
before the election.
But it's definitely
it looks like it's going to be f
And I think that's another windf
for President Trump,
because, as you say, it's
certainly the weakest
of the criminal cases.
It has the least gravity to it.
It might not even come
with a real serious risk of impr
It's that weak of a case in that
And it's also predicated
in part on witnesses like Michae
So it's the case
that if he were to wish to go fi
it would be that one.
All right, Brian, thank you very
I mentioned the Georgia case
as well in this context.
And there was a bombshell
admission in that case today.
The Fulton County
district attorney, Fani Willis,
finally admitting
that she did
have a quote, personal relations
with her top prosecutor.
The announcement coming almost a
after the scandal first broke.
Now, Willis
filed a 176 page court filing.
In it, she argues,
there are no grounds to dismiss
or to remove her from the prosec
So she's fighting back
and she's countering accusations
that she financially benefited
from the relationship with Natha
There are a lot of specifics as
And Paula Deen is OUTFRONT
in Washington Paula.
You've had a chance to go throug
176 pages.
What have you learned in there?
A lot.
Erin, as you can see, it is volu
This is the first time
they are publicly responding
to these allegations.
Let's go through
some of the things that we've le
First of all,
we know
Nathan Wade was appointed in 202
but he revealed today
that what he describes
as a personal relationship
with Fani Willis actually began
So after his appointment
and they say it
grew out of their preexisting
professional relationship.
But, Erin,
as you know, the accusations
from former President Trump
and his co-defendants
are not limited
to concerns
about a personal relationship.
They also point to the fact
that Wade has earned
hundreds of thousands of dollars
while overseeing this high profi
And during that time,
he and Willis have gone on vacat
and he has at times
paid for some of those expenses.
But today, Wade denied
that his earnings
had been shared with or provided
to Willis, saying, quote,
At times
I have made
and purchased
travel for District
Attorney Willis and myself
from my personal funds.
At other times, District Attorne
has made
and purchased travel for
she and I from her personal fund
This is basically saying
when we travel together,
we split the check.
Now, Willis, in her part of this
she insists
that none of this meets
the legal requirements
for her to have to be disqualifi
from this case.
She insists that
none of the substantive decision
that have been made here,
the charging decisions,
the plea deals that have been br
None of these have been influenc
by their personal relationship.
So all of this sets up
a February 15th hearing,
Erin, where the judge overseeing
this case will consider
this disqualification question.
Now, among the witnesses
who could be called Willis and W
and some of their colleagues.
So not surprising
they are seeking to have
that hearing canceled.
All right. Thank you very much,
So I want to go to Michael Isiko
the chief investigative
correspondent for Yahoo!
News and the coauthor of Find Me
the Votes.
It details the inside
story of the case led by Finding
against Trump in Georgia.
So, Michael,
you've spent an enormous amount
with her while writing your book
You've spoken to Wade as well.
Were you surprised at all
by the revelation that they had
this this personal relationship?
I guess they say this goes back
very significant that they're sa
after he was appointed. Right.
So he was appointed because of i
I want to emphasize
that's what they're saying here.
But were you surprised
that the relationship was even g
I think it's been pretty clear
for the last few weeks
that there was a
relationship there,
a intimate relationship,
Finding Willis, all but acknowle
that when she gave that speech
at the at the black church
on Martin Luther King Day.
And quite sad
but if you read between the line
But look,
you know,
I think this filing today
could go a long way
to diffusing this whole controve
if you take a step back.
The motion filed by Ashley Merch
the lawyer
for Michael Roman,
one of the defendants,
basically argued
that there was a financial
and personal conflict of interes
here because, number one,
Fanny Willis
hired somebody
she was having an intimate relat
with, paid them lots of money
and then used that money
so that they can all go on
lavish vacations.
So if in fact, the relationship
had not begun at the time,
she hired him
and they shared the costs of the
that kind of really
knocks down the predicates
for some of the motion.
The idea was
that somehow
they wanted to prolong this case
so they could.
So Nathan Wade
can make more money to take Fann
on lavish vacations.
That was speculative from the st
You add these two facts
and it kind of like undercuts th
for the motion.
There's going to be a hearing Fe
15th.
We'll see whether
the judge
wants to get into an evidentiary
But I'd be surprised at this poi
if he does.
All right.
Tempest pushing these accusation
against Willis and Wade, of cour
Here's some of what he said.
She paid her
boyfriend, a lawyer
who had no experience as a lawye
and no experience doing, what,
almost $1,000,000.
And then they decided to go on
beautiful Norwegian
cruise lines trips all over the
He was a very generous person
with our money.
Now, again,
they're saying it didn't start
until after he took the position
And I would presume
that if that's not the case,
people are going to come forth
out of the woodwork
and make that clear, right?
Yes,
they're swearing the fact that i
So.
But you write in your book
that Wade was not even at
the top of Willis is less.
So this would mean
not only did the relationship st
after he was hired,
but in fact, that she herself
did not even want to hire him. E
She had a hard time
finding anybody to take the job
as we write and find me the vote
I mean,
she reached out
to a number of high profile
people, Roy Barnes, the former
governor of Georgia,
gay banks, a former
highly regarded federal prosecut
And they turned her down. Why?
As Roy,
as Roy
Barnes is quoted in her book,
in his in our book,
hypothetically speaking,
do you want to have a bodyguard
following around
for the rest of your life?
They were worried about the thre
that were coming from Trump supp
and something that finally Willi
was experiencing every day.
And just briefly, so much
so these threats that
she had a body double.
Yes.
This is one of the most
dramatic, extraordinary stories
of this whole saga
the night of the indictment in A
where she makes that
late night announcement.
It was about midnight to all the
corps,
the Fulton County staff
had picked up an assassination
threat on a MAGA website.
The best time to shoot her is
when she leaves the building.
So they arranged this whole elab
decoy operation.
Funny Wolf goes back from the pr
Congress to an office
or office takes off her
black business suit
and pearls,
gets hot, puts on sweats
and a baseball cap
and a body
double somebody on the staff
who resembled funny Willis,
you know, puts on the business s
underneath a cop over a Kevlar
bulletproof vest and drives out.
Funny was
is smuggled out
the back door of her office
to an undisclosed location.
All right.
Well,
I hope people will read more
because that is an incredible st
Sad but incredible.
Thank you so much, Michael.
I always glad to see you.